g'day have you ever seen one of these
it's an abacus
it's an ancient counting device still
used by merchants in some parts of the
world to this day one uses the beads on
the rods record numbers and by sliding
the beads on the rods we can change the
numbers and thereby do arithmetic we're
going to use the abacus as inspiration
for today's lecture actually it's going
to be inspiration for all the arithmetic
and computation for the rest of this
course so to get get us going let's
spend a moment learning how an abacus
works here's a very simple version of
abacus it has ten beads on each of a
series of rods each rod represents a
place value for a number and beads on
that rod are used to represent the digit
in that place value 0 1 2 all up to 9
for example here's a picture of the
number 2341 on a simple abacus we see
two thousand three hundred four tens and
1/4 to add 425 to this number for
instance just slide up four more beads
in the hundreds place two in the tens
place five in the ones place and we see
the answer 2766 appear right before your
eyes great
that's addition but of course there
could be a complication suppose we now
want to add the number 204 to this
answer of two thousand seven hundred
sixty-six we can do it we can slide up
two beads up in the hundreds place and
four up in the ones place but we get an
ass that doesn't quite sound right 2906
tens and ten ones ah but we realize that
ten ones is the same as one ten so the
thing to do is to slide the rightmost
set of ten beads down and start up one
bead in the tens place in their stead
ten ones are replaced by one ten and now
we see the answer two thousand nine
hundred and seventy which fits with how
we speak our numbers okay those very
proficient at using an abacus can do
this process of caring without even
thinking converting ten ones to 110 ten
tens to 110 hundreds to one one thousand
and so on I myself and slow and need to
think carefully every time I try playing
with an abacus
especially if the carrying needed is
more complicated an example we just did
and it usually is more complicated I
should point out that a modern abacus
uses fewer beads than 10 on each rod
they have special beads separated by a
bar each worth 5 sliding be to the
central bar means they are being used to
example here's how the number eighteen
thousand two hundred seventy-six appears
in a modern abacus so proficient users
of the modern avec i are very good are
not only carrying groups of ten as
needed but they also good at keeping
track of groups of five within groups of
ten it is very impressive
alright that's all we need for a basic
understanding of a Bacchae and i said
that i want to use the abacus as
inspiration for an idea a visual idea of
course to explain or rithmetic so here's
how my visual idea goes instead of rods
i'll draw boxes just as rods in abacus
represent a place value ones tens
hundreds thousands and so on each of my
boxes represents a place value - and we
have as many boxes as far to the left as
we please that is we can have as many
place values as far as we ever willing
to go so now instead of drawing beads
I'm going to draw dots dots go into the
boxes and they give us the digits of the
numbers we wish to represent for example
here's the number 2241 in our dots and
boxes picture and just like an abacus we
see the number before our eyes the thing
I want to point out is that our schema
of dots and boxes actually dynamic if
ever we find ourselves with ten dots in
a box they explode kaboom and disappear
to replace with one dot one place to the
left so for example if we ever see ten
dots in the unit's place they explode to
become one dot in the tens place ten
ones the same as 1/10 and if ever we see
ten dots at a tense box they explode
Kapow become one dot in the Hondas box
ten tens is 100 and so on ten dots in
any box always explode and disappear to
become one dot one place to the left to
express this dynamic action I like to
call this dots and boxes schemer a ten
machine we didn't fight backward
notation to indicate how dots actually
explode so let's now practice putting
dots into the machine let's put in 24
dots and dots always go in the right
most box here they are do you see a
group of 10 anywhere in this picture why
sure
and then 10 dots explode gets wack to
become one dot one place to the left is
another group of 10 yes indeed they
explode to creating a second dot one
place to the left
Wow now there are no more groups of ten
no more explosions but we can see that
the machine is doing the right thing for
us put in 24 dots and we get the read
out two tens and four ones
grand alright let's do another example
let's put in 273 dots into the machine
okay here goes well actually rather than
draw 233 dots is it okay if I just write
the number 273 in the rightmost box
instead I hope so
alright so let's think through what this
machine will do first will it be any
explosions why yes
okay how many explosions 27 one for each
group of 10 and what any dots be left
behind you think about it yeah three
dots will be left behind
all right so 27 explosions each
producing 1 dot to the left makes for 27
dots in the second box and three dots
are left behind now will there be
another round of explosions sure to from
the grips of ten leaving seven behind
great and that's it never you see it no
more explosions to be had and we see the
number 273 spilled out before us
actually I just did something
interesting I described the number 273
as 273 ah notice we are literally
literally say two hundreds seven 10s
that little T Y is actually short for
ten and three we speak the language of a
10-1 machine when we speak on numbers
huh all right so we've got the language
of numbers down pat now let's do
arithmetic
let me goes through the algorithms I was
taught in school and maybe you taught
these ones too but use the 10
machine to make clear good sense of them
in fact I'll tell you that the 10:1
imagery is we're about to do is so
powerful that I will never again use the
algorithms I was taught to us in school
the 10:1 thinking is actually so much
clearer let's start with addition
consider the sum 273 plus 512 now the
long addition algorithm I was taught in
school had me write matters this way
line up numbers by columns I was taught
to compute the sum from right to left
which to me was odd because I was
actually taught in school to read left
to right so let me be contrary and just
do the summation from left to right and
see what happens 2 plus 5 or 7 7 plus 1
is 8 3 plus 2 is 5
and we get the answer 785 which is
actually correct and philosophically
this approach is right in a 10-1 machine
293 looks like this two dots seven dots
three dots and if I add 512 to it that
as I add five more hundreds one more ten
and two more ones I get this picture
indeed seven hundred eight tens and five
ones
so going left to right or right to left
either way is just fine okay
but I hear you say that additions can be
more complicated than this okay so let's
try a juicier one let's try for example
our 258 plus 167 say all right going
from left to right we get 2 plus 1 is 3
5 4 6 is 11 and 8 plus 7 is 15 the
answer is 311 T 15 e whoa now what I
said sound absurd but the answer is
actually mathematically correct and
valid the dots and boxes show it to be
so two hundreds five tens and eight ones
add one more hundred six more tens and 7
more ones and you really do get three
hundreds 11 10 and 15 ones 311 T 15 is
absolutely right but the trouble is
society doesn't let me speak this way so
how can we fix up this answer so that
others can understand it well we can do
some explosions 10 dots can explode from
group of 15 for example and leave five
dots behind and adding one dot one place
to left so he now have 312 t5 ok still
curious but we can explode again this
time from the pile of 12 and now we see
the answer of 425 the world understands
what I'm now saying fabulous so why we
taught to conduct long additions from
right to left in school when working the
other way is actually fine well let's
look at the right to left school
approach for a moment studying at the
right we have 8 plus 7 equals 15 but we
don't write 15 we write 5 and add 1 to
the tens column that's actually an
explosion right there now we have 1 plus
5 plus 6 is 12 but we only write 2 and
explode another 10 adding extra 1 to the
hundreds column and then we have 1 plus
2 plus 1 makes 4 for hundreds and we can
see the answer 425 so it's just a style
thing I'd like to do all my work from
left to right and do then do all my
explosions the very end the traditional
algorithm goes from right to left and
has one attend to all the explosions as
one goes along and that schemer
explosions are usually called it carries
the math max doesn't care one way or the
other
all correct math is actually correct go
right to left left to right you'll be
fine
all right so let's do another example
let's try this big one let's try 37,000
and 295 plus 20 4859 all right going
from left to right I get the answer five
eleven ten fourteen fourteen fifty
eleven thousand ten hundred fourteen t14
it's very fun to say it's a quirky way
but can you now see how to fix this ass
up for the rest of the world for their
understanding well the world says that
we should do the answer is sixty-two
thousand one hundred fifty four and we
can see it happen take a moment if you
like to see how to get this particular
answer for example 10 dots explode from
the eleven leaving one behind adding one
dot one place to the left that gets to
six one ten fourteen fourteen and so on
I really do find it so much easier just
to work left to right write down the
answer and then fix things up for the
rest of the world later on so be quirky
it's good all good
correct math is actually good and
correct but let's do a change of scene
now let's just the multiplication let me
now ask something like what's two
hundred forty three thousand one hundred
ninety two times four
okay hmm well can you see what the
answer must be and a 10-1 machine so
here's the number in the machine again
I'm writing digits rather than drawing
dots I really hope that's okay
so we're being asked to call Drupal this
number so let's just pull it right now I
have to 100 thousands for dribbling must
give eight of them we have four ten
thousands quadrupling must give 16 of
them three thousand score to report
makes twelve thousands one 100
quadra-port for hundreds nine 10s
quadrupled 36 tens and two ones
quadrupled makes four eight once the
answer the problem is just 8 16 12 4 36
8 816 to 12,000 430 68 if you like to
say things in a quirky way ha and now we
can do explosions to fix this adds up
for the rest of the world if we like and
if you want to try it you'll get the
answer 970 2768
okay addition multiplication now for
subtraction now we saw in an earlier
lecture I don't really believe in
subtraction to me subtraction is just
the addition of the opposite so this
means we need to work with the opposites
in a 10-1 machine so we need to work
with the opposite of dots now I call the
opposite of a dot an anti dot earlier
and we drew anti dots as hollow circles
and recall that a dot and an anti dot
together
annihilate one another to just disappear
like matter and antimatter so here is a
traditional subtraction problem 1478
take away 353 lined up by columns so to
me this is a particular addition
problems it really is 478 plus the
Antti version of 353 that is 407 tens
and eight ones plus three anti hundreds
and five anti tens and three anti ones
and here's a picture of it we see after
annihilations we are left with just one
hundred two tens and five ones the
answer is 125 just beautiful it is
though again I just went from left to
right I said 4 take away 3 is 1 7 take
away 5 is 2 8 minus 3 is 5 and I'm done
ok I know you were thinking that was too
nicely problems so what about something
like I know 423 take away 254 well
let's still go from left to right 4 take
away 2 is 2 2 take away 5 is negative 3
3 take away 4 is negative 1 the answer
is 200 negative 3t negative 1 and this
is correct it's actually mathematically
sound answer here's the Dotson boxes
picture for hundreds and to anti
hundreds two tens and 580 tens three
ones and for anti ones and after
annihilations really left with two
hundred three anti tens and one anti one
yep
200 negative 3t negative one so now the
question is how could I fix this up for
the rest of the world to understand hmm
all right well here's something clever
we could unexploded one of the dots in
the hunters place after all it came from
ten solid dots in the box before it so
here's the picture we get if we
unexploded ah'd and after some
violations we see we now have seven dots
in the tens place we have the answer 170
negative one still correct still good
still a bit strange so how about one
more an explosion sure let's unexplored
a 10 stops to produce 10 dots in the
ones place and now we see the ants of
169 appear before us and the world
understands that answer do
see that the traditional subtraction
algorithm we were taught in schools uses
an explosions as well one exploding is
actually called borrowing so let's start
from the right let's ask what is three
take away four and you say can't be done
well we unexploded one of the dots from
the tens place and actually make that
313 actually that piece really confused
me as a child
three magically changing to 13 it was
weird but actually it makes sense to us
now it's an unexploited
we unexploded to add 10 dots to the
three and we now have 13 take away four
and we can get nine now the tens place
we have one take away five at present
and that can't be done so an exploit
from the hundreds place and make it 11
take away five and get six and finally
in the hundreds place we have three take
away two which we can do it is one the
arts of 169 appears so again it's just a
style thing be quirky like me and go
from left to right and do the unexposed
at the end or go from right to left and
unexplored as you go along
either way is totally fine so we've done
now three of the four basic operations
of arithmetic in a 10-1 machine with our
addition some multiplication and
subtraction and we've made superb visual
use of place value in our thinking tens
hundreds and so on but we move on to the
fourth but let's move on to a fourth
arithmetic operation division but I want
to taking the time now and pause don't
reuse the remainder to lecture to really
take the notion of place value in and
see how surprisingly general and how
powerful it can actually be so let's
just hold off on division for a moment
and let's go to the table top and talk
about dots and boxes in different types
of machines okay time for some hands-on
fun dots and boxes but little bowls and
little stones this time so I'm gonna
play with this here's my road boxes
going as far to the left as I please
so imagine they can keep going if I want
them to and we're going to put these
stones as my dots in these bottles as my
boxes alright but instead of doing a
10-1 machine I'm gonna change things now
and do instead a two one machine how is
that going to work well I guess two one
means two dots when they're in a box
what explode kaboom become one dot one
place to the left
so if there're two dots in a box kaboom
one dot one place to the left hence a to
one machine all right I think that makes
sense let's do it let's put in dots in
our - one machine and see what codes we
get for numbers
all right our first dot remember dots
always go in the rightmost box there we
are
Jim one dot doesn't seem to do much
justice there is one dot okay so the
code for one is one alright no worries
because here comes a second dot what's
the code for two and A two one machine
there's the second dot two dots on the
box they explode kaboom and become one
dot one place to the left
hence the code for two is a bunch of
nothing's one zero and a to my machine
the code for two is one zero
all right third dot what's the code for
three don't always go in the rightmost
box
Jim all right how much happens code for
three is one one for a fourth dot I was
feeling this one's going to be
particularly exciting here comes the
fourth dot always the rightmost box lube
two dots on the Box exploded kaboom and
become one dot on place to the left
- I saw the Box explode Kapow they come
one dot one place to the left so we see
the code for for now is one zero zero
oh this is fun let's do five v dot Jim
OH
how much happens one zero one six Jim oh
there's an explosion Kapow
one dot one place to the left and six
has the code one one zero hours of fun
working at the codes of different
numbers fact let me be wild let's give
us through a few numbers now got to 13
let's put 13 dots in this machine in
fact I'm going to be really wild and
puts 13 dots in all at once
let me count out 13 dots 3 6 9 12 13 and
here they go into the machine or is the
rightmost box I get a whole pile of dots
beautiful will there be some explosions
you bet lots of explosions
here's explosion two dots there's two
explode kaboom
make one dot one place to the left
another two dots there they are
Kapow another two dots King another two
dots good fluke there it is the two dots
go swing go flip all right
but there's more explosions the fun
doesn't stop two dots explode cuz youth
kazeem does wack and another explosion
good loop and now I'm done there it is
there is the code for the number
thirteen one one zero one says you're
kind of fun playing with this we can
actually see the codes coming before our
very eyes
alright so like we asked for the ten
mana Sheen I need to know what is this
machine really doing ha
alright well as before I set up this
machine so dots here always worth one so
let me write that you write a stripper
stripper paper here dots here in this
position are always worth one great and
then we said whenever there are two dots
in a box they explode kaboom and become
one dot one place over to one machine to
ones must be mean that this dot is worth
to two dots here they will explode
kaboom
become one dot one place to the left
hence this this must be worth two twos
which is four ah now we see what's going
on two fours make an eight to eight
would make a sixteen and to 16s make a
32 and so on look at that this is now
using the doubling numbers the powers of
two in fact we said I recall that
thirteen was one one zero one and you
know what we can see we are right one
eight one four no twos and one one eight
four and one does indeed make thirteen
so that's what's going on with this
particular to one machine it's numbers
in base two
no longer base-10 like us humans have a
predilection for its now based - it's
called binary writing numbers this way
is called binary and we only use the
digits ones and zeros in binary which
actually is a very convenient system in
the world of computer science because
computers actually work on electrical
switches that are either on or off so
actually it's good of a way to encode
arithmetic in computer science using
just two symbols 0 or 1 for on or off so
binary is the natural way to think of
arithmetic in a computer but of course
we can keep going with our fun we did a
10-1 machine we've done a 2:1 machine
just keep playing with the numbers how
about a 3:1 machine so how would that
work well a bit all this gonna be
different so I'll take it away so a 3:1
machine would be put in three dots in a
box and wherever that happens they
explode k'tau become one dot one place
to the left all right so let's try it
let's get some codes for a 3:1 machine
let's start the beginning put in 1 dot
not much happens stays as 1 dot the code
for 1 and a 3 one machine is 1 put in a
second dot ah nothing happens we need 3
dots to explode in a spree one machine
so the code for two in a 3-1 machine is
2 however here comes a third dot and the
code for three is now k'tau one got one
over one place over the code for three
and that's for your machine is one zero
dot number four gives me the code 1 1
dot number 5 is another code 1 2 6 gonna
be exciting here comes 6 up 3 explode
kaboom one dot one place over the code
for six is two zero in fact you only get
zeros ones and twos this time all right
well I did 13 for a to one machine so
let's do 13 as well for a 3-way machine
so it's back to 13 coins so there's 4
and 3 then a 7 another 3 and another 3
all right
so there
is 13 coins a three-one machine and they
put them all in at once and see what
happens he goes three explode here's
three kaboom 1.1 place over three
explode get POW if I can pick them up
there we go
kaboom 1.1 place over another three
splode your zip Oh
I'll explode those ones for now for fun
why not do you are but I still got an
explosion over yonder
jingle one dot one place over and that's
it four explosions the code for 13 is 1
1 1 in a 3-month machine alright same
question what is this machine really
doing well let's do the same sort of
work we did before I've always set these
machines up so dots in the rightmost box
always worth 1 dot there is worth 1 all
right one but three dots here we said
are equivalent to one dot here three
ones means this dot must be worth three
and three of these guys could you make
one of those so this must be worth three
of these ones three threes is nine and
three of these glasses Explorers kaboom
make one dot over yonder this was it
this was three nines makes 27 and so on
81 243 729 etc alright so as a check we
set the code for 13 and a 3-1 machine
was 1 1 1 were we indeed right can we
actually see it's true why yes 1 9 1 3 &
1 1 does indeed make 13 1 1 1 is the
code for 13 and a 3-1 machine so we
discovered now base 3 and this is called
ternary arithmetic actually there could
be a good use for these two because
there's talk of making optic computers
computers based on 3 different states of
light like that license are the
polarized in one direction why there's
polarized maybe in the
particular direction or maybe no light
at all so computers based on polarized
light will have three states one two and
no state no light so that means it will
be best to represent arithmetic in a
system that uses three symbols like
zeros ones and twos so actually base
three this ternary arithmetic would be
very appropriate if ever computer
science starts to work with optical
computers in fact we keep playing with
this game we can do for one machines and
discover base for 500 machines the
discover base 5 we could do ninety to
one mission czar discover base 92 if we
like not sure how that would work be
hard to write down but we could if we
really wanted to grant do you know what
we could actually get very quirky and do
something very strange
we did a to one machine we did a three
one machine well if I did a mixture of
those effect let me write it up here
what if I did a 3-2 machine ha so let's
be very clear how would that work well
it says that whenever there's three dots
in a box that explode become two dots
one place over all right I'm quite sure
what's gonna happen here but let's let's
get some codes for numbers let's just
put in some dots one dot well not much
happens stays as one dot so the code for
one in a 3-2 machine is one second dot
hmm not much happen it stays as two dots
we need three dots to exploit to become
two so the code for two in a 3-2 machine
is two he comes the third dot and
whenever those three dots in the box
Kapow they explode become two dots one
box over so the code for three is now to
zero very strange here's the code for
for the fourth dot boom to one here's
the code for five he comes v dot boom
two - no explosions yet we need three to
explode ah but six is going to be
exciting here comes the sixth dot bump
to explode
Kapow become two dots on place over then
three slowly goes kaboom
and two dots one place over so the code
for six is now two one zero
very very strange what is this machine
doing well says I did 13 for the other
machines
let's do 13 as well for this one let's
see what 13 looks like encoded in a 3-2
language of some kind
whatever that language is here comes 13
dots there's 3 + 3 + 3 + 3 + 1 makes 13
there they are here they go in the
machine three dots explode to become two
three dots there they are explored
become two Cobell three dots explode and
become two kaboom three dots explode it
Kapow
kazeem goop and become - I'm do it again
three dots explode
swak and become - alright
still more explosions three here can
explode and become 2/3 here can explode
- OH
kaboom and finally I see another three
dots in here they can explode cuz u p--
become - so the code for 13 in this very
strange machine is 2 1 2 1 so now the
real challenge is what is this machine
doing what base Oh Ian we're not in base
- it's not like binary we're not in base
3 it's not like ternary it's something
else and actually I'll give it away
we now it's something that people can
call base one and a half which is really
really bizarre so welcome to base one
and a half something is between being I
know - ish and three ish if you like
very strange very fun in fact you can
work out codes of all sorts of numbers
in base one and a half this way use try
to figure out how to do arithmetic in
base one and a half if you want to if
you're feeling really you bald about it
go for it I say mathematics does not
care in which base we write our numbers
or the arithmetic we did today
work exactly the same way for any
machine there's absolutely nothing
mathematical special about base 10
so why are we humans so partial to the
number 10 well the answer could well be
our Anatomy we have 10 fingers we use
our fingers for counting and it seems
natural to us to associate the number 10
with counting and arithmetic only
because of our biology actually there
are many cultures that use base 20
instead white base 20 well they must be
thinking of their fingers and toes in
fact we have vestiges of base 20 in a
Western culture too if we sample how
does the Gettysburg Address begin four
score and seven years ago how many years
ago is that actually well a score is 20
years so four score and seven is four
20s and 787 it's a little bit of base 20
language huh as another example how do
you say 87 in French I forgive me otter
I speak French but I believe it's cut
over set and that's much better than
Rogers did but word-for-word this
translates as 420s 787 is for 20s and
seven it's based 20 yet again the point
is that we can use any base we like in
computation and arithmetic mathematics
does not care because biology we might
go with base 10 or base 20 and that
feels convenient for us the computers
with on-off switches base 2 is
convenient and if we go with optic
computers with 3 States base 3 will be
the way to go so now that we've got our
base and place value fully under our
intellectual grasp let's now move on to
the final arithmetic operation its
division and it's actually mighty fun so
I'll see you next time for it